-Hi, Kevin.
-This is, like, so awesome
I'm gonna be honest with you
I only made the movie
so I could come do this.
-Well, this is
working out great then.
-It really is.
When the publicist was like,
"What do you want
out of the movie?"
I was like, "I want
to go on 'Seth Meyers.'"
He said, "Why?"
I said, "I'm a huge fangirl.
I watch this show every
damn morning when I wake up,
but it's so weird
to be, like, looking at you,
'cause normally I wake and bak
and watch the show.
-Oh, gotcha.
-So it's so strange to be
looking at you not high.
-Yeah.
-Like, I love the show so much
I'm so dumb and don't know
what to think in life.
So I love "A Closer Look."
You tell me
what to think and stuff.
-Well, you should think
on your own. Oh, okay.
-No, there's no need for that.
-Okay.
-I love -- And all night long,
since I've been here,
I keep running into people
who I'm like, "You're famous!"
I saw Karen before she went out.
-Yeah.
-I was like, "Oh, my God!"
The guy who brought me bac
here, the stage manager,
he's like, "You go on in five.
I'm like, "I've seen you on TV!"
He goes, "Yeah, quite a bit.
It's so awesome for me, man.
I love the show.
I'm a big fan.
I love "Amber Says What."
You know what I love?
I love the dude that's
just like, "Leave him alone!
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-I love that guy.
-John Lutz. Yeah.
-You guys --
I love "Popsicle Schtick."
I love -- There's a bit you did.
And you only did it once,
and I wish you'd do it again
Where you were, like, the
conservative point of view
and the liberal point of view,
but it was all about
giant openings.
-We can order all this up.
-Oh, my God.
That's why I'm here,
to request things.
But in any event,
can I tell you, like any fan -
You know, it's like,
"I love everything you do,
but there's one thing
I don't like."
For me, people are like,
"I love everything you do,
but except everything
after 'Clerks.'"
So the one thing you do
I don't agree with
is when you do day drinking.
-Okay.
-I'm like, "That's not my Seth."
I don't like when you do that.
-Gotcha.
-That's not -- Like,
that's not New Hampshire, son.
-No, no, no. You're right.
-You don't do
that sort of thing.
I always wished that
you were stoning instead.
And so since I watch --
Since I watch the show
like all the time,
like, I'm a big fan.
I had this idea,
and you got to bear with me.
-Okay.
-So, I -- I make my own weed
-You do?
-Yeah.
-Congratulations.
-This is called Snoogin.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm not saying --
'Cause I know it ain't,
like, legal in New York.
I'm not saying, like, smoke it
Can we just put it in the mug,
like, with the pencils
so that every time I watch
the show it's always there
-Um, it's --
-No. You can't say no.
But if you want to say no, here.
I scripted something for you
to say no with.
This might not work.
I was so blazed
when I wrote this.
One of my favorite things
that you do on the show,
and you don't do it
very regularly,
is every once in a while
you do, like,
a distinguished
Southern gentleman accent.
-Oh, yeah. Yeah, yeah.
-So I wrote a script for you
to do that with me right here.
-Okay, great.
-And I'm hoping to turn it
into my ringtone.
-Okay. Great. Okay. Great.
-So, let me just set it up
-Okay.
-It's says "Interior --
'Late Night' studio, night
Kevin gives Seth a joint
that he requests
live permanently
in Seth's desk collection.
Seth, unwilling
to insult the guest
by denying the request,
stalls by inexplicably
slipping into his
Southern gentlemen impression.
-[Southern accent]
"What a thoughtful
and yet somehow simultaneously
self-serving gesture,
my new Northern friend.
I find myself much obliged t
you for so generously affordin
my humble house
this stickiest of icky."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I'm in heaven!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Shut up! Shut up!
There's so much more!
-There's so much more.
There's a bunch more.
You have a line now.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Here's my line.
"Then you'll keep it
on your desk in the mug
with all the pencils so that
when I watch the show
from now on
I'll always feel like
I'm a little part of it?"
-"It breaks my heart
to have to decline your
herbal offer, good sir.
But the minute
my writers got wind
that this sweet green
essence of life
was just a-sittin' in a cu
on my desk,
that juiciest of jiz-oints
wouldn't last
a Mason-Dixon minute.
No, instead -- instead
we shall remedy this situation
with a post-show smoke session
back at my home
with my wife
and my tiny children.
With great Southern pride,
I do declare us friends
forever, sir!"
-And scene!
-That was really nice.
Very well written.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I -- I don't know
if this is worth anything,
but now you can go
on the IMDb and list
"I've been directed
by Kevin Smith."
-I do want to --
While I've enjoyed all this time
talking about me,
this film, you're returnin
to these characters
you've been doing
for a very long time.
This film is making fun
of the idea of reboots.
-Yeah.
-It should be noted.
-It's a movie that makes fun o
sequels and remakes and reboot
by being all three
at the same time.
-And you're taking it -- You'r
going on the road with it.
You're watching it
with audiences.
Is that enjoyable?
-Oh, I love it so much.
We've been on tour
since October 19th.
We've got like 65 dates.
I'm on city 50.
No, 42 right now. Show 70.
And I've watched every one
I sit there with the audienc
every night.
1,500 people. And watch it
I sit behind them in the back,
stare at the back of their heads
like a dirty little cuck.
And I'm just waiting
for their heads to bop
'cause if they do, I'm like,
"I'm funny. I'm clever."
And I feel good and stuff.
So, people have asked me like,
"How many shows
have you sat through?"
I'm like, "Every one.
I sit there and watch them
with the audience every night.
They're like, "How much do you
hate this movie by now?"
I'm like, "I don't,"
because, like, it's --
Going to that movie
every night on tour
is akin to going to church
where I'm both the priest
and Jesus himself.
-Yeah.
-So it's really like
a religious experience.
The fans go nuts like "The
Rocky Horror Picture Show,
people are screaming
at the screens.
I didn't realize
that would happen.
First night of the tour
was in New Jersey.
We opened in Asbury Park.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And so -- Yes, and, so, when w
were there, I had no idea --
I wrote it to be funny I hope,
but, like,
it became interactive.
Like, Brian O'Halloran
plays Dante in "Clerks."
He's the first character
you see on screen.
When he popped in,
the audience went nuts.
They're like, "Wah!" And I was
like, "That's amazing."
And then I was like, "You know
what? It's New Jersey.
They better treat him like thi
'cause all they got is
Springsteen and this guy."
But, then, it kept
playing really well.
So, we went to Chicago
the next night,
and Chicago
blew their doors off.
It was even louder
than New Jersey,
so much so that I was like
"Forget New Jersey, man!
They don't understand a prophe
from their own midst."
So I go every night and se
the show, but I started shooting
the audience and the movie
so I could clip it out
and text it to people who
aren't there to get to see it.
Like, my wife was in "Jay an
Silent Bob Strikes Back."
She pops up for a minute i
"Jay and Silent Bob Reboot."
When she does,
the audience goes nuts.
And I shot it
and sent it to her.
I was like, "Can you believe
they even remember you?"
Like, it was amazing. And sh
wrote back, "F you, Kevin.
But my favorite one, hands down,
was Ben Affleck's in the movie
When he pops up,
the audience reacts like
Batman swung in to save the da
or something like that.
So I shot that.
The big reaction in Chicag
was huge.
And I texted it to Ben.
I was like,
"This is what they think of yo
in Chicago, Batman."
And he wrote back
a two-word response. "I know."
And that was it.
-Well, it is just a deligh
for people who are fans
of the franchise.
And what a pleasure
having you here, Kevin.
-I love being here, man.
This is huge.
-I cannot thank you enough
Please come back again.
-Thank you so much.
-Kevin Smith, everybody!